The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
CHRIS BOEBEL: So anyway, I'm
Chris Boebel and, as I said,
I'm the Media
Development Director
at the Office of
Digital Learning, which
is what the K-12 video
project is part of.
As well as MITx, and OCW, and
a bunch of other initiatives
on campus, I also teach a
documentary video class--
a science documentary class--
here at MIT that Elizabeth
took a few years ago.
And what I'm going to talk
about is storytelling.
And specifically,
visual storytelling,
and how that can relate--
or hopefully will
relate-- to the work
you do in this class
and to online video in general.
I'm going to start out
just by taking maybe-- I
don't know if it's
exception-- but just having
a slightly different
perspective than something
that Elizabeth said.
I would say that almost all
videos that are successful,
almost all viral videos,
have some element
of a story to them.
Even a five second Vine video.
Just about everything.
And I actually was
thinking about that,
and I went looking
for what is probably
one of the dumbest viral
videos to come out recently.
Just a few days ago.
You may have seen it.
This is a fan at Ohio State
who was caught on the Jumbotron
basically scratching
her boyfriend's head
and then picking her nose.
And this thing
got-- I just, it's
ridiculous how much play this
got in about a 12 hour, 20 hour
period.
Very ephemeral, you know.
It's absolutely
not going to last.
It's not going to
change anyone's life,
but the reason it took off
is that it has a story.
And the story was
created and invented
by the people who watched it.
You know, it's not
really-- yeah, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: I thought the
point of that video--
I saw the same thing
that she was with--
that's like the guy she
was seeing on the side--
CHRIS BOEBEL: Exactly.
AUDIENCE: --that's
not her boyfriend.
CHRIS BOEBEL: That's
actually not true.
That was the story that
was completely created
by people who watched it.
They've been together
for a long time,
and she didn't even know
she was on the Jumbotron
actually, apparently.
But it just happens to be
this kind of little moment
that tells a story, and
because it told a story
that people related to, suddenly
it turned into a giant thing.
One thing that's hilarious is
somebody actually reversed it,
so she picks her nose
and then sort of leaves
a deposit on his neck, and
that became another story.
AUDIENCE: There's
something disturbing
about her facial expression.
CHRIS BOEBEL: Yeah exactly.
She looks guilty.
She looks guilty, and that's
why that's part of the story.
Like, oh my god, I've been
caught rubbing his neck.
So anyway, I think
this has got to be
the dumbest viral
video of all time,
but I think it's also a story.
Never think you're
not telling a story.
If you forget everything else
that I say in the next 30, 40
minutes, I would remember this.
There's some element of
a story in what you do.
I don't care if you're
making an FDA approval
video, as one of
you mentioned you
are interested in
doing-- something
I've actually done personally.
I don't care if you're
making a 30 second TV
commercial, a 10 second TV
commercial, a 12 minute physics
demonstration.
There is an element
of story to it.
And it may not be the sort
of conventional, traditional,
"television" story that we
would see on an HBO show.
It may not be a
Hollywood movie story.
But there is an
element of story,
and one of the things
that you want to do here
is find what those elements are.
Now, let's unpack
that a little bit.
Let's talk about
what is the story,
and how might it relate
to what you're actually
going to be doing here.
And then secondly,
we'll also talk
about what are some of
the specific techniques
of visual storytelling that
you might be able to employ.
So first of all,
what is a story?
Full confession.
I went to film
school and I worked
in that sort of ancient medium
that Elizabeth talked to,
television and film.
And the classic and traditional
way of talking about a story
is that it's got these things.
It's got a protagonist, a hero.
It's got an inciting incident.
It's got something that happens
that sets everything in motion.
Then there are barriers
along the way, problems
that the protagonist
has to overcome,
and then there's a resolution.
So you do that in a kind of
traditional, classic way,
and you end up with
connections, or worse, right?
It's not going to
work, obviously,
in the genre that
you're talking about.
Another way of looking
at this traditional way
is that you've got act
one, which is the set up,
you've got act two,
the barriers, the plot.
You've got act three,
the resolution.
The three-act structure is kind
of the classic screenwriter
mode that you see
over and over again.
So how does that relate to
what we're actually doing?
Well, this is going
to be somewhat
repetitive to some of the
things Elizabeth talked about.
First thing, clearly,
that you need
to do in this very short
form is engage your audience
immediately.
I mean you've got maybe, like,
five, six seconds, maybe eight
or ten, to engage
them on some level.
That's the beginning
of your story.
That's the inciting incident.
And then this is something
that I find very interesting,
and you know when I
talk about web video,
this is something
that is a paradox,
that I think is
really, really true.
You want to surprise
your audience, while also
showing them exactly
what they want to see.
And this can be
really a challenge.
Surprise your audience.
In other words, you want to
take them somewhere, show them
something that's
fresh, that's new,
that they haven't seen before--
something Elizabeth just
mentioned.
But at the same
time, you really want
to-- you need to sort of
feed into their expectations,
because otherwise they're
going to shut down.
And that is why a lot
of the YouTube channels,
and a lot of the people who
do this work for a living,
have a genre that they stick to.
Smarter Every Day, ASAP, Vsauce.
You know-- hey, I always jump
up from beneath the frame.
That's my thing, you know?
So you're showing
people what they want.
At the same time, you're
surprising them and taking them
somewhere they've never been.
And it's kind of a
paradox, but I think
it's kind of a key paradox.
And then the last thing
is, leave your audience
wanting more.
Shortness, brevity, is a very
important thing, particularly
for this.
I mean, this is a
series, Science Out Loud.
The nicest thing
for Elizabeth would
be if somebody said, oh
my god, that was so great.
Click, next one.
Now if you think
about it, this is
very similar to a
three-act structure,
it's just a really compressed
three-act structure.
Engage your audience--
the inciting incident.
Surprise your audience,
and also showing them
what they want to see.
This is sort of the
development, which
might only take 30 seconds.
And then, leave your
audience wanting
more-- some kind
of resolution that
takes them to the next thing.
The other element of
all of this that's
very important to
just briefly mention--
and Elizabeth mentioned
this earlier--
is that in online video, just
as we saw with the Ohio State
clip, a lot of the storytelling
happens outside the frame
of your video.
You want to, basically,
be able to leverage that.
So people's expectations
before they see your video play
into how they perceive your
story, their experience during,
and then what they do after.
All of those are part
of the story, as well.
So, you know, the naked
celebrity picture-- well,
that's kind of a
story too, because you
have an experience of
Brad Pitt in one context,
and then suddenly,
wow, is that his butt?
That's a story.
Not a very good one,
necessarily, but.
I also want to talk a little
bit about protagonist.
I started out talking
about one of the things
you need is a protagonist.
Well, on one level,
the protagonist
is you, if you are the
host of this video.
And if you think about the sort
of videos Elizabeth showed,
all of them, pretty much
on one level or another,
have a protagonist.
It's a very strong character,
a very strong protagonist,
whether it's crazy Russian
science guy, or the Smarter
Every Day sort of down-home
but super-smart science guy,
or Vsauce.
Love him or hate him, he's
a very strong character.
So having a protagonist
is really, really,
really important.
That protects is going to be
you in this particular instance,
but there's also
another protagonist
that we should talk about,
and that's your audience.
Because what you're doing is
taking people on a journey
through this learning, and
some of the barriers that
are going to be
thrown up are barriers
to their understanding.
Think about Smarter Every
Day and the cat clip.
The whole thing is structured
around, oh hey, now we know,
it's the tail.
Oh-- no it's not.
No it's not, it's
something else.
And that happens
two or three times
over the course of the clip.
That is, basically, a story.
That's storytelling.
There's a barrier to
understanding-- oh,
we think we've solved
it-- no, we haven't.
It's like a car chase.
It's like breaking into a safe.
It's like a lot of
things that you would
see in a conventional movie.
So there are actually
kind of-- in some ways,
you can think of it
as a dual protagonist.
You, the trusted guide,
are taking your buddy,
the audience, on this journey.
On a story.
To return to what
I said earlier,
I think of web videos--
great web videos
are like great snack food.
They're very familiar,
yet they're also
sort of spicy and enticing,
and after you have one
you just want to have another.
And then you have
the second one,
and you just think, maybe
I should have a third.
Hopefully the videos you
make won't leave people
with heartburn, which is
what happens when you eat too
many of these, but
that is, to me, kind
of an interesting analogy.
And if Interstellar,
or some three hour
opus that you pay $10 to
sit in the dark to watch,
is a seven course meal at
a four star restaurant,
you're making
something that's just
got to be really tasty and
delightful for just a moment,
and leave people
wanting another one.
Just exactly like that, but
somehow subtly different, too.
I'm not going to show
any video, because I'm
going to try to just talk about
the videos you've already seen,
rather than show.
So let's unpack stories
just a little bit more.
I've made the case that
you're telling a story,
and you should never forget
that you're telling a story when
you do this kind of work.
Well, what are stories
actually built on?
There's a whole list of
things, and Elizabeth
has mentioned a couple of them.
Emotion.
Now, I'm not necessarily
talking about Gone With the Wind
emotion, but certainly
curiosity, identification,
humor, which is an emotion.
All of those things
really are going
to play into what you do and
are very, very important.
Character.
We've talked about character.
Conflict.
Again, not necessarily
high drama, but there's
often some kind of conflict.
The conflict may
be, oh, you thought
the cat was using his tail
to spin, that's not the case.
But some kind of conflict,
barriers to understanding,
I think are very,
very important.
Spectacle.
Again, you're not going
to do Interstellar,
you're not going to spend
$100 million on CGI,
you're not going
to do The Hobbit.
But often-- it's another
word for taking people
a place they've never been.
Maybe you can get into
the nuclear reactor here.
Intellectual engagement.
I think that's kind of the
obvious one, the easy one
that we can all think
about when we're talking
about educational videos.
In and of itself, I
don't think it's enough,
but it's certainly
an important one.
And there are plenty of videos
out there-- plenty of lecture
videos-- that basically
just depend on that.
And then the last two are
two of my favorite ones.
The unfamiliar
becoming familiar,
which is kind of the
classic science video.
But the familiar becoming
unfamiliar, as well.
In other words, you
think you know farts,
but you don't, despite
all you know about farts.
And in one context, you don't
know that much, and here's why.
So I think both of
those are really
interesting structures for
you to use to hang a story on.
Again, the first one, obviously.
I'm going to take this thing
that you don't understand,
and I'm going to
make it completely--
I'm going to demystify it.
But a lot of science
education is also
about kind of taking something
that seems really simple
and showing just how
complex, and intriguing,
and unfamiliar it really is.
Now let's talk a little bit
about visual storytelling,
because that's obviously
what you want to do here.
Lecture videos--
again, intellectual
engagement certainly
one way to go.
If you use OCW, as a
couple of you mentioned,
you know very well that lecture
videos can be effective.
And in fact, lectures
can be great stories.
We all have had
experiences of people
who are great lecturers,
who tell great stories.
And those stories may
or may not be visual,
but I think there's
certain things that
distinguish visual storytelling
that are worth talking about.
And this is a
concept that I often
use to just kind of get into
to this whole idea, which
Elizabeth will
probably remember.
This is what we sometimes
call the plastic elements
of video or a film.
And sometimes I use film
and video indistinguishably
because-- it betrays
my age-- video is film,
film is video now,
at this point.
What I mean by the
plastic elements of video
are, just simply,
all of the things
that we have control over
when we make a video.
And that could be the
casting of the actors,
it could be where we
put the camera-- that's
kind of the obvious
one-- the lighting,
there's an endless
list of things.
And, in fact, here are
just a few of them.
Again, most people would
list the camera right away,
since that's kind of the
"paint brush", quote unquote.
The lighting, how we
choose to light something,
or whether we're actually
literally using lights or just
using the sun or
existing room lights.
Editing, sound, music,
characters, the actors,
locations, props, costumes,
the list is really endless.
It goes back to the decisions.
Elizabeth mentioned
decision-making.
All of these things are
things you need to think about
and you can control.
And they can work for you,
or they can work against you.
Think about in Smarter
Every Day, props.
The cat itself, of
course, is a great prop.
Think about the stuffed
cat at the beginning,
which is that sort of fun
moment of, oh my god, he's
really going to drop a real cat.
That was a choice.
That was a choice, to
add that stuffed cat,
and it sort of made a fun
little moment that brought you
in for just a second.
Locations.
Very, very important.
I mean, the sort of lowest
common denominator location is
a chalk board or a white
board for something
like an educational video,
but there are all sorts
of other possibilities.
Costumes.
Again, doesn't have to be
clown costumes or silly hats,
or things like that--
although it could be.
But all of the other things that
you can, or might be able to,
bring to your video by
making these choices.
Camera, of course,
is a crucial one,
and I'm going to unpack
that just a little
bit as well, although
we could spend hours
talking about film grammar.
So I'm going to just go
through a few other tips
to think about.
The first one-- and this
is kind of like the bible
of visual storytelling--
show, don't tell.
And it sounds kind of obvious,
but it isn't necessarily
that easy to do.
If we think about
the sleep video,
I think one of the things that
I responded to in that video,
that I thought could
have been better,
is that it's actually
not showing us much.
It's telling us.
Elizabeth talked about the
fact that the voiceover just
read, like, a web article.
Like, a sort of "10
Facts About Sleep",
and that's basically the case.
I mean, there is some
really cool animation,
and the animation is fun, and
it helps, and it definitely
supports the words,
but together,
it's really just this
thing-- you know,
I could have listened
to it on my iPod.
I could have listen
to it in my car.
The visuals helped a little
bit, but it didn't really
add anything to it.
The other way to do it, of
course, is Smarter Every Day.
Which again, you may or
may not have liked that.
You may have thought that
it dragged on too long,
and I agree with that certainly.
I think there were things
that could've been improved,
but there's nothing
like dropping a cat,
and showing it in super-slow
motion, to get my attention.
So I think that was a great
example of showing something.
This is just something
that I wanted to mention.
Having worked in
television, there
was a saying that
went around a lot
when people were talking about
a script, which was, "Oh, this
is kind of a wolfpack deal."
And what was meant
by that-- this
was sort of an infamous
situation from, I don't know,
God knows when.
Somebody who's scripting
a nature documentary
had written this long,
very beautiful, kind
of flowery narration about
"the ravenous pack, lopped
across the frozen tundra
in search of its prey"--
blah blah blah.
Like two pages of sort
of beautiful prose,
and at some point in
the editing process,
somebody was like,
because they had that.
They didn't need to
say all that stuff.
This picture was worth
endless amounts of stuff.
So avoid your pack moments.
If you don't need to say
something, you can show it.
There may be plenty
of things to say,
and I'm not saying that
it should be all visual,
but you don't need to say
certain things if you're
already showing those things.
Use your language,
use your words,
which are very important
to do other things.
To reinforce, to bring
your own perspective,
to embellish the
story, to bring people
into your own mind,
your own character.
You don't need to say
the obvious stuff.
You don't need to do the
wolfpack description.
So that's show, don't tell.
The other thing that's just
sort of a fundamental tip
is, video loves motion.
Moving pictures.
And Josh is going to talk about
storyboarding and animation
later in the week.
Clearly, animated
pictures, moving
things, things that reveal one
thing or another in animation,
are really important.
Same with cameras.
If you look at Science Out Loud,
some of the other episodes,
you'll see some really terrific
moves with the camera, dollies.
All of those things
add visual interest
and improve your storytelling.
Locking down a tripod can
also be very effective,
but again, think of it
as a plastic element
that you can control.
Don't do it just because
you didn't think about it,
do it after thinking about what
you're doing by either moving
or not moving.
So the camera loves motion.
This is kind of the
corollary to that.
And I don't know if people have
a lot of shooting experience
or not, and this
isn't really strictly
a class on the
production techniques,
but this is something I
really wanted to mention.
Motion for the sake
of motion is also not
terrific, not fantastic.
Hosing down the room
is that tendency
that your uncle or
your grandfather
has when you give them a camera
to just do this all the time.
And you're going, oh, hey,
I'm getting everything.
I'm just getting
everything here.
This is fantastic.
And in fact, what you get
is absolutely nothing,
because there's
no intentionality.
There's no sort of
thought to what's
happening with the camera.
All you're doing is
making everybody seasick
and really pissed that you're
not focusing on anything.
Motion is actually--
I think a better way
to talk about it, in
story terms, is reveals.
When you're moving
things, you're
revealing the next
story element.
So if I pan from our
camera person over to Josh,
and Josh is looking over at the
camera person, is going like,
why is he doing what he's doing?
That's a story element.
Whereas if I do this, I'm
not telling a story at all.
Same with animation,
and I'm sure Josh thinks
about this night and day.
I mean, how do you
reveal your next thing
from the thing you've got?
How you go from this
idea to that idea?
How do you reveal using motion?
Because it is moving pictures.
So that's maybe a
more pointed way
of talking about
motion in story terms.
Revealing things.
I'm going to talk
just a little tiny bit
about grammar, and framing, and
stuff like that, very quickly.
This is just a still
from an interview
that I did a couple of
years ago here at MIT.
Joel Dawson, a professor here.
And just a couple of
things to just point out
about it in terms of,
sort of, just the way
it's visually set up.
First of all, you'll
see that the background
and the foreground
are very distinct.
We shot it so that the
background is completely
out of focus, and that's so
that you know what to focus on.
That's the other thing.
So we talked about reveal.
The other sort of
key crucial thing
to think about when you're
storyboarding, or creating
animation, or directing
is, how do you
get people to look
at what you want
them to look at in the frame?
One way is to foreground
the foreground
and let the background drop
off, either through lighting
or through the
focus, in this case.
Or through art direction-- there
are all sorts of ways to do it,
but doing it is
really important.
The other thing is that
this is a close up.
Sounds kind of simple,
sounds kind of obvious,
but it's making
a choice to go in
and to find out about
this guy, this person.
It's not about the lab.
It's not just sort
of this wishy-washy,
moving shot of him wandering
around his lab doing something.
We want to hear what
this person is saying,
what he's thinking, right now.
Just another quick thing
to just talk about.
When you're shooting in this
particular format, 16x9,
there are a couple of
really powerful parts
of the frame that you can use,
whether you're doing animation
or shooting, and
they tend to be where
the thirds cross each other.
So that's a very powerful
part of the frame.
That's also powerful.
These are powerful in
slightly different ways.
And you'll see his eyes, like,
dead-on in the crosshairs.
If we're people who read
left to right, in sort
of the Euro, European
tradition of writing,
this tends to be the
most powerful point,
because we read frames left
to right, because we're
used to our eyes used
to going that way.
Not saying you have
to follow this rule.
You can break it, but it's just
an interesting thing for you
to know.
When you're framing things,
when you're creating animations,
there's a tendency when you
start to think oh, dead-center
will be really great.
But it's actually not the case.
A little off-center and in
sort of the thirds of the frame
is a good way to go.
The other thing just
to talk about quickly,
in terms of making
choices, think about--
and this will really come up
when you do your storyboarding
exercises with Josh--
think about what
the kinds of shots
you choose are doing.
Wide shots say one thing,
close-ups say other.
Starting with a wide
shot and coming in,
that's a reveal of something.
But starting in a
close-up and going wide
could also be a reveal
of something else.
I think we can imagine
what kinds of stories
might come out of
these two frames,
and how the story
might be different
if we started here
and went here,
and if we started
hear and came out.
So make choices, and think about
what your choices are actually
going to do in
terms of the story.
Another example of that.
Camera angles framing.
Low angles looking up, that
gives you a certain feeling,
it gives you a
certain kind of power.
A sort of master
of my domain feel.
The opposite, looking
down, kind of the opposite.
These are just two
examples, and I'm not
going to go on and on and on and
talk about others, although we
may get into it
later in the week.
The point is that the camera is
one of the key plastic elements
that you have at your
disposal to tell your story.
And the medium shot, just
kind of center frame,
doing your thing, is
kind of the fall-back.
You don't have to do that.
There are any number of
other choices you can make.
And when you start to go and
choose locations, and choose
props, and choose
elements like that,
how you shoot those things and
how you shoot your characters
becomes very, very,
very important.
And then the last thing that
I'm going to talk about--
and I'm kind of racing through
this because I want to just
make sure we have time
for questions and stuff--
I'm just going to be a
little counter-intuitive.
We've been talking about
visual storytelling,
but just don't short
change your sound.
Sound is often more
important than the picture.
And one of the other
things that I think--
Elizabeth talked a little bit
about production technique,
and quote unquote "bad
technique" or rough videos,
versus slicker TV-style videos.
One thing that's very,
very, very hard to overcome
is poor sound.
And even if your
video is a little out
of focus and its shaky,
if it's really compelling,
that's fine, as long
as the sound is good.
But as soon as the sound is
bad and hard to listen to,
you're going to have a really
hard time pulling people back.
So even though this is mostly
about visual storytelling,
I just want to point
that out, that that
doesn't mean that the
sound is not important.
In fact, the sound is
extraordinarily important.
And it's both a technical thing
but also a plastic element
that you can use.
Whether it's music,
or sound effects,
or the way you treat
dialogue, all of those things
are really important.
So just to contextualize
this a little bit,
I know that Elizabeth's
co-instructor, George,
is going to be doing a
scripting workshop with you,
and he's going to be focusing
a lot on finding your voice.
Which is really,
really important,
and goes back to the
idea of character,
and the protagonist,
and authenticity,
and a lot of the things
Elizabeth was talking about.
But as you do that, as you
do all of those things,
remember that ultimately
you're telling a visual story.
And that once you, sort of, hone
your story, hone your voice,
you want to put that
in a visual context.
You don't have to have the
words carry everything.
And in fact, the
words may end up
doing other things than
conveying the core of what
you need to do.
So that's it.
I kind of tried to
race through it,
because I didn't want to
keep people for too long.
First of all, any
questions or thoughts?
AUDIENCE: I just had a
thought, just a question.
It was interesting, you
mentioned that the-- I'm sorry,
the name's escaping me-- the
whiteboard video that you were
critiquing earlier--
PROFESSOR: ASAP Science.
CHRIS BOEBEL: Oh, the
ASAP Science, yeah.
I liked it, I didn't
mean to dump on it.
AUDIENCE: No, I think
it was really important
and a really interesting point.
So then I was
thinking, okay, what
would have been more effective?
How could that have been
turned into some sort of more
storytelling
exercise, or something
that was more engaging?
And I think it would be an
interesting question, just,
how could that be better?
And my feeling was, would
it be better to do something
where you actually
had someone not
sleep for overnight,
or for two days--
CHRIS BOEBEL: Well I think
that's-- yeah, no, go ahead,
yeah.
AUDIENCE: Something
like Supersize Me,
where you have someone
actually engaged in this thing,
and it's more
experiential, as opposed
to being didactic I guess
would be the distinction there.
So that was just one idea.
CHRIS BOEBEL: I think
that's a really good point.
I mean, that's kind of
the Smarter Every Day
approach, which I respond
to personally better.
On the other hand I think
that there are graphics
that tell amazing stories.
I think data visualizations
that I've seen recently,
in particular, just can be
extraordinary storytelling
devices.
So it's not so much that I
think that it was animated,
and somehow that was
not as effective.
It's that I think the process
was write script, and then come
up with stuff to fill in space.
So yeah, I personally
respond more
to the ones that are
more experiential, where
you have people-- that may also
be supported by animation--
but there is someone taking
you through the experience.
But I do think that there
are lots and lots of ways
to tell really, really dynamic
and really interesting,
good stories with animation.
AUDIENCE: That's good to hear.
CHRIS BOEBEL: Oh no, totally.
And you know, we've
all been there.
I've been there, too.
You have something that you
have to make come alive.
I think they did a great
job of making it come alive.
I think the animation
was really effective.
It's just that I
think the approach was
to write a script without
necessarily thinking
about the visual medium,
and then to take the visuals
and layer them on top as a
separate part of the process.
So anybody else have
any-- I mean again, I know
I kind of raced through it.
How many people-- I mean, do
you have video experience?
How many people have some
kind of video experience?
That's always a really
good question to ask.
No?
Nobody?
Well that's cool.
That's great.
AUDIENCE: You have bad habits.
PROFESSOR: Absolutely.
Absolutely.
I think, just to go
back a little bit,
I think that whole relationship
between web video and TV
is a really interesting one.
It's a really interesting
one to unpack,
because again, the sort of
conventional storytelling
techniques that we're
used to seeing on TV
are not going to be effective
for all sorts of reasons.
It's also worth mentioning
that of course TV
has changed too, radically,
since connections.
Game of Thrones
doesn't open that way,
two minutes of somebody
wandering around a house.
But at the same time,
it is a different genre,
and really a crucial thing
is the thing that Elizabeth
alluded to, and I
mentioned at the beginning,
that I think you're
telling a story,
but your story extends beyond
the bounds of your video,
or can extend beyond the
bounds of your video.
It basically can begin with
what people's preconceptions are
before they start watching,
and it continues on
after the video is done.
And I think that is a
really crucial difference.
One suggestion
that I would make,
whenever you write
something this week--
and you're going to
be writing treatments,
and pitches, and
scripts-- think about it
in purely visual terms.
One of the early exercises
that I had to do,
when I was in grad
school, were silent films,
and films or versions of scripts
that had no dialogue, had
no sound at all.
And I think that's-- I'm not
saying that you should do that
as a technique in
your finished piece,
but it's a way of bringing up
stuff that you can then apply
to your video later.
So if you were going
to do something
that was purely visual, that
was going to convey what wanted
to convey, how would you do it?
And what might you create,
or invent, or think about,
through that process,
that you can then
use to inform your script.
So just a way of thinking
about what you're
going to be doing this week.